in south africa racial tensions have
sparked outside a high school in cape
town the school was on
high alert today after parents and
protesters violently clashed on monday
now president ramaphosa has condemned
the clashes and called
for an investigation demonstrators had
picketed at the school on monday after
rumors that a
matrix leaving party was attended by
only white students
dw's correspondent adrian kriesch
reports from
breckenfeld high school inside the
school students are writing their high
school leaving exam
outside is a massive police presence the
school also hired security guards
after parents and protesters clashed
close to the school
on monday we need to see a wrist because
that is absolutely unacceptable
violence from any side and of course at
the end of the day for me
we have to allow the learners
to complete their year specifically the
matrix
they need to be able to do it safely the
police closed down the street in front
of the school but
down here on the other side you find a
group of parents and their supporters
they say they came here to protect their
children
in case the economic freedom fighters
are showing up again the eff the
political party organized
the protests on monday that turned
violent and some angry members of the
white community attacked the protesters
even beating them with baseball bats
they refused to talk to us but
on the other side here today you can see
only a few protesters showed up
this is called white privileges
why is there always color involved what
the [ __ ] is that
what do you think the whole issue is
about what's this whole issue about
why do you think this whole issue is a
private function error don't don't
nonsense to me man
so why wasn't the black children invited
this is an issue about race
racism we need to deal with it wherever
it surfaces
you understand because for too long
we've been tolerating these people
they didn't apologize for apartheid but
they still cocky about their racism
and how can we allow it right we are
still suffering under their racism
this thing is going to boil over let's
go this thing is going somewhere
the situation outside the school is
another example for racial tensions in
south africa the neighborhood here is
mainly white
and although the students in the high
school are mixed in race the eff
claims that there hasn't been a black
teacher for many years a claim that the
authorities have neither denied
nor confirmed tensions are likely to
remain high
with the eff announcing further protests